in florida we are going to tell about
you to go to hell
and he should be
[Applause]
yo yo yo i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it is
tuesday may 24th in the year 2022 and
that was florida governor ron desantis
and he was speaking
at mar-a-lago
and mar-a-lago of course that's donald
trump's
country club uh interestingly that is
the first country club in all of west
palm beach florida that allowed black
people and jewish people into the
country club he's a noted anti-semite
and racist so i thought that was worth
note and that is uh prev i almost said
president ron desantis have i led too
much that is governor ron de santa
speaking at
mar-a-lago and i thought we would start
with that as the cold open because
something interesting might be brewing
right one of the big questions that i
got when i was on tour was what is going
on with these two which one's going to
run for president what happens if they
both run for president are they talking
are they friends etc etc as if i have
great insider knowledge on that i mean i
might have a little insider knowledge
but i don't have any insider knowledge
that i can share with you at this very
moment uh so i thought it was
interesting because there's desantis
showing up to mar-a-lago and given a
talk and really given a talk about uh
what i want today's theme to be
which is they are going to try to scare
us again a lot of you have been
messaging me and saying dave you haven't
said anything about monkey pox yet i
just got back yesterday but monkey pox
it's out there people are freaking out
and what does the system do every time
we take two steps forward it scares us
to take three steps backwards right we
know this and they're freaking us out
about monkey pox i want everybody to
calm down we have some actual facts and
information
for you
and uh don't trust the people who have
been lying to you all along and we've
got video to prove that they've been
lying and scaring to you scaring you for
quite some time and if you fight back
maybe we can win it's not just ron
desantis that has to fight back it is
you
as well quick reminder if you want to
see me and the governor perhaps future
president in orlando we will be there on
june 2nd at the plaza live theater
that's right i'm going to give about a
40-minute talk and then about a
45-minute interview with governor ron
desantis a couple tickets left
daverubin.com
events and before we get to all of that
i want to talk to you guys about bonner
private wine do you know what's in that
wine bottle sitting on your kitchen
counter
no traditional media they just won't
tell you try oak flavoring mega purple
dye and tons of sugar and that's not
counting all the chemicals left over
from vineyards that look more like oil
refineries than the great chateaus of
old but better wines do exist and they
don't cost an arm and a leg either take
it from america's top wine explorer
recently he came across a wine unlike
anything he's ever tasted problem is
this delicious red wine can be only
found in a single isolated corridor
known as the world's most remote wine
valley heck he nearly died twice trying
to find these vineyards that's a lot of
times the wine that is that special want
to give him a try today head over to
bonner private wines and my audience can
get these rare wines at half the retail
price no need for a promo code plus
you'll get 50 off shipping the wine is
truly something special but supplies are
limited visit bro bonner
privatewines.com dave to claim your wine
that's bonner privatewines.com dave and
now back to me okay so look
we're out of covid they're gonna bring
coven back i know some people have covid
right now it's becoming just the thing
that you get and you sneeze a little and
maybe your legs hurt and okay whatever
and if you want to take more precautions
you should you know my feelings about
locking people in their houses firing
people forcing people to be injected
with things mandates etc etc but i sense
that the system has realized that the
jig when it comes to covid is up many of
us and i can really tell you this from
uh from touring that i was polling my
audience how many of you did not get
vacs and a huge i would say 75 percent
of my audience did not get vaxxed i did
not get vacs i was very proud of people
to make their own decision i can tell
you the type of applause that people
gave when they applauded and screamed
and cheered that they didn't get vaxxed
uh because people were proud that they
stood up to the system and then there
were some people in there who did get
vacs and they felt they had to they were
frontline doctors and nurses there and
everyone had to make horrible choices
with all this but the point is that what
they really tried to do was scare the
hell out of everybody
for a virus that had something like a
99.997 recovery rate and really was only
killing people over 80 years old with
other comorbidities like diabetes
and being overweight etc etc and all of
this stuff so the average covid death
age
believe it or not was higher
than the average age of the population
okay than the average age of death all
right so anyway all of that being said
uh they're realizing that they're losing
us on covet a little bit because they
they scared us a little too much and too
many people wisened up to it uh so now
they're into this monkey pox thing and
people are freaking out there's a couple
cases of monkey pox and uh here's biden
warning that monkey pox is coming and uh
oh we might have a vaccine question one
of your health advisors told you your
level of concern should be about monkey
pucks in the cases that are in the
united states and around the world well
they haven't told me
the level of exposure yet but it is
something that everybody should be
concerned about we're working on it hard
to
figure out what we do
and what uh
vaccine
it is a concern in the sense that if it
were to spread it's consequential
they haven't told him the level yet but
it's something we should be concerned
about and uh we're thinking about the
vaccine he just has no idea what's going
on he's a complete [ __ ] con artist
he has a mental problem he's old okay
fine so be it now a lot of people are
going where did this thing come from
there's some rumors that it came from
some raves a bunch of people having
raves
having sex at raves in europe i don't
know and look i don't know about
vaccines but i can tell you here in
florida we're growing a tremendous
amount of bananas right now here's my
backyard yesterday look at this that is
me
cutting bananas from our banana tree
that's clyde in the background and i i'm
not saying that the monkey pox came from
the bananas i'm not saying that bananas
are what can cure you let's get the
close-up on the bananas do we have the
clothes look at these bananas these are
the bananas i have in my kitchen right
now who wants a banana after the show
you want a banana they're not cut
they're not quite ripe yet we're gonna
have to wait on the bananas anyway
they're gonna try to freak us out about
this and i think it's extremely
important that we do not fall for it
twice right
because they're going to keep trying to
make us fall for it they're going to
keep trying next thing you know we'll
have monkey pox lockdowns and the rest
of it so here's some reality in case
you're freaking out about monkey pox
we've got some info from fox news a
leading advisor to the world health
organization described the unprecedented
outbreak of monkey pox in developed
countries as a random event that might
be explained by sexual behavior at two
recent raves in europe dr david hyman
who's formerly head-headed who's
emergencies department told the ap
that the leading theory to explain the
spread of disease with sexual
transmission amongst men at raves held
in spain and belgium monkey pox has not
previously triggered widespread
outbreaks beyond africa where it is
endemic in animals so endemic in animals
meaning it's just kind of there it's
just kind of there and animals get it
and then some of them die and that's
what it is
some of this can be transmitted by skin
to skin touching and sex trying not to
have sex with someone with monkey pox
you'll probably be okay
uh but yes suddenly
he is telling us joe biden is telling us
that there might be a vaccine for it
have we seen
this script before do you guys get it
it's just more fear in the system and
why would they
be putting more fear in the system well
it does seem remember for those two and
a half weeks when we were all freaking
out about abortion that kind of quieted
down didn't it isn't that something did
they shoot that one off too early like
they thought that one was going to
really carry us through the summer and
now they're also warning us of the
summer of violence um but they want a
certain amount of fear in the system and
as i said i think people are just sort
of not as afraid of covet anymore i
think people have realized boy we were
all wearing masks on planes nobody
really wanted to then we all took them
off
and we're all okay and let's not forget
remember about four days before that
wonderful judge judge mazzell the 35
year old trump female trump appointed
judge in tampa said take the masks off
on planes about five days before that
fauci was extending
the federal mass mandate on airplanes
now everyone took the masks off and have
we seen crazy spikes in kovid no of
course that have we seen crazy spikes in
death no of course not because they lie
and lie about everything and it is
important for us to not be ruled by fear
and to figure out how to fight back that
is the theme of today's show and real
quick guys i want to talk to you about
start mail you ever wonder how big tech
knows so much about you three words free
email services when you click accept on
those terms and conditions you're giving
that free email provider the go ahead to
scan and analyze your email free email
services are data hoarders they're not
free if you're done letting big tech
make billions selling the info in your
email i suggest switching to start mail
start mail keeps your email private
period every email can be encrypted even
if the recipient doesn't use encryption
when you delete an email from start mail
it's gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazon's which
means they can't put better they can't
be put out of business if you're already
dropping big data orders like facebook
and jumping onto less censored platforms
perhaps like locals then right now is
the perfect time to switch to start mail
switching to start mail is seamless too
you can easily transfer all your current
email data so there's no starting from
scratch start mail is backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous aliases so when
you're giving your email to a company
but want to protect your identity start
mail can generate a shareable alias
email so people can't sell your info and
they can be deleted at any time i keep
saying the way forward is to build
competitive businesses that support our
privacy values which is why i value the
service that start mail provides your
cyber security has never been more at
risk email snoops and scammers are
taking advantage of the pandemic as
fishing has skyrocketed in the last year
keep your private info private with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
fifty percent off your first year go to
start mail.com
reuben that's start with the t mail.com
slash ruben for fifty percent off your
first year and now back to me
all right so first today i am going
as i lay out the case of they're going
to try to scare the hell out of you
people
i'm going to now conor do we have the
warning i'm going to show you something
from the view okay content advisory what
you're about to see yeah it's going to
be scary but believe it or not
i'm going to start what you're going to
see here to start i don't want to tip
away too much but you're going to see
the start is joy behar making sense
which is very very weird joy behar is
going to make sense then sunny hosting's
going to take it away but joy behar is
going to make sense
but the theme really here is that biden
scares us and we should not
trust any of these people anymore and
when i say any of these people i mean
fauci i mean the cdc i mean the who i
mean the world economic forum i mean the
buffoons on cnn the crazy people on
msnbc and certainly the harpies at the
view
it's a match
that's right the npr doesn't want the
covet to spread yeah so they're telling
their people if you're a fellow employee
sitting there without a mask i want to
hear about it report it to hr i think i
would never do that on italian we don't
snitch
because snitches get stitches we don't
snatch look i think it's a good thing
because
we've been terrible to each other during
this uh pandemic i i think you know
remember patty lupone was was uh at the
theater and she had to really dress
someone down yeah a theater goer and
saying you know protect us we're here
without our mass our audience is all
mass because you guys are protecting us
because we cannot be masked right now um
and and i think you know there are times
when you want you see someone let's say
on an airplane when we had the the mask
mandate and they had the mask basically
you know around their ears like earrings
or like chin guards and if you said
anything they would fight you about it
and this the flight attendants had to
say stuff so i i just think you have
this this mechanism now where you can
just call
and snitch
and protect yourself as opposed to
taking it on yourself
somebody just snitching on somebody they
don't like
my god i can't believe it joy behar
and what's her name anna cabrera
actually made some sense we'll get to
sunny in just a second joy behar i'm not
going to snitch on people now first off
joy behar would snitch on people right
she's a crazy leftist maniac there's
just no doubt that if her makeup woman
and the woman takes on a lot of makeup
if the makeup woman came in without a
mask of course joy would be snitching so
it was a joke but uh whatever i'll give
joy a little credit on that one and anna
navarro my god she said something
sensible there at the end how do you
know that people wouldn't just snitch on
people they don't like that's
interesting anna navarro you got one
right it's i don't know what's going on
here but now let's do sunny hostin who
is a complete idiot she's a racist by
the way um she seems to think that
people should snitch on each other at
work and that it is your responsibility
to
make sure that other people take medical
precautions that you see fit not just
that you should be responsible for
yourself so if you want to take whatever
precautions you want and if you want to
wear a mask and if you want to wrap your
head in saran wrap and put a ziploc bag
on and industrial strength tape around
it and all that stuff that's your
position but that also you should be
making sure that other people who don't
do the things that you want them to do
are potentially fired
so the point of all of this is why would
we listen to these people as this monkey
pox thing
seemingly is disseminating and what i
mean by that is it's disseminating
through the media more than anything
else i'm only talking about it today
because i want everybody to freaking
calm down about it more than anything
else but these people it just goes to
how if you just scratch
you just scratch a progressive what's
underneath
that thin layer up top is a real
authoritarian they really really want to
control you she really wanted to control
those people on planes instead of just
putting on a mask herself
and just letting it be right she really
wanted to control people um now we've
got more so this is uh biden's kovidzar
his name is ashish ja
saying that if you get kovid you don't
have immunity for life even though no
one's ever argued you would have
immunity for life but they want to scare
you into thinking it's coming back and
your natural immunity ain't gonna work
what are you learning about these repeat
infections in terms of what it means for
immunity and all also the severity of
these infections
yeah it's a really good question i mean
first and foremost i think we can now
dispense with the misinformation that if
you get infected once you have immunity
for life you know a lot of people have
argued that we knew that always that
that was not the case
the second thing we're learning is that
this virus is evolving i mean the virus
is evolving relatively quickly trying to
escape our immunity
no one i never did you ever hear anyone
say that if you got coveted once you
would never get it again now of course
he says i want to dispense with the
misinformation about that no one ever
said it no one ever said it people said
there's something called natural
immunity meaning if you got it once you
had a certain amount of immunity for a
certain amount of time you might not get
it again for a certain amount of time or
you might get a lesser version that's
how the human body works that's how
antibodies work right
everyone said that i never heard
literally one person say if you got
covid you would never get coveted again
now what's interesting is he doesn't
address the fact that i know a gajillion
people roughly i'd have to check the
numbers on the spreadsheet and and so do
you uh of people who got kovid
got vaccinated got coveted again got a
booster got covet again
got another booster got coveted again
etc etc etc so it's just endless
nonsense from these people and i don't
want you to be afraid of monkey pox the
way they have made us afraid of kovit am
i making myself clear here now there's
this guy bill gates now bill gates if
you don't know him he's this soy
drinking rather grotesque his body have
you seen the picture maybe we can get
the picture that connor could throw it
in a little bit that picture of him in
the sweater it's really quite horrible
but he created microsoft he created
windows
windows of course and microsoft i mean
these were products that although they
were ubiquitous and they were on
everybody's computers and you know
microsoft paint was nice and all that
they had gillian viruses on them right
every time you opened up your pc there
were a million viruses everything would
be slowed down pop-ups blah blah blah
well
he brought us the virus on the computer
and now he's somehow seemingly trying to
save us from covet and everything else
you may remember this video from a while
back how do we prevent something where
we don't even understand how it came to
be like you know are there labs where
they need to do better at
you know enclosing the work that they're
doing i understand that they have to do
the work but how do we figure that out
and how do we move forward in that realm
well we shouldn't be careful about lab
safety
it's quite clear in this case that it
came across through animals and almost
all our diseases like hiv crossed over
from chimpanzees in africa quite some
time ago ebola came from bats uh
this also uh with one step in between
came
uh from bats so it's going to keep
happening particularly with climate
change where we're invading uh
a lot of habitats
uh and you want to catch it as soon as
you can how do we do that well you see
people getting sick
you
you see
elevated deaths and you go in there and
you actually take and you sequence it
early on
and then you have a global group right
that is ready to go kind of like a fire
squad
uh comes in and very quickly you
diagnose people
he's just such a weirdo freak i don't
even know what to say like what does he
have to do with covid response now i get
it he's got a lot of money and when you
have a lot of money people seem to think
that you know everything about
everything and he's got his foundations
and all of these things but again he
created software and what did that
software do it got put on basically
every computer and then every computer
got endlessly infected with viruses i
don't think that's much of a jump to
sort of what's going on now exactly why
he's involved so involved in our modern
virus situation then he tweeted this out
yesterday and i had to go after him for
it he said movies like outbreak nailed
it when they imagined a global disease
fighting team who is ready to respond to
a crisis on a moment's notice now we
need to make it a reality before we get
to my response though uh if you remember
the movie outbreak with uh dustin
hoffman and who else was in it the guy
who molested those kids uh that guy was
in it and uh that woman was in it who
was the guy the main guy who molested
those kids
uh the guy who was in that show
who's that guy
the main guy he's not in anything
anymore he was in that show on that
kevin spacey thank you
thanks guys
great team over here um
sorry there's a long list of people in
hollywood that molested kids um
everyone's like well that's your kids
well we've got pages of painting here
uh
outbreak the whole
movie basically is about how corrupt the
government and everything and the whole
system is and then yes a few people i
guess eventually he shoots the little
monkey and they save the people okay
fine anyway he tweeted that out and i
felt like i got him with this retweet i
felt this was pretty good everyone hates
you and that's why you shut your replies
on all your tweets you mega megalom
maniacal soyboy weirdo um i feel like i
nailed that one uh candace owens though
she's pretty solid when it comes to
responding to these people too she has a
way that we can respond to the next
pandemic and that's just soy boy bill
gates in jail if you think of being a
little unfair with the with the soy and
everything here it's just like no you
gotta go away man and we have to mock
these people into oblivion what does
bill gates have to do with your life or
my life did anyone vote for bill gates
did anyone say bill gates should be in
charge of our health or our vaccinations
or any of these things but we've got
plenty of proof
that their policies are terrible the
policies of the democrats of the left of
the machine when it comes to lockdowns
faxes mask mandates they do it all
for
political gain and they tell us they're
doing it and for some reason a certain
amount of people seem to just love it
and that's what we're going to bring you
home with here on today's show but real
quick i want to talk to you about real
estate agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust we
work with only the best real estate
agents in every market we do our
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join our network and
here's a big one we only work with
full-time professionals no part-time or
inexperienced agents our team makes the
intro and then follows you through the
buying or selling process to make sure
that you're satisfied the agents we work
with have long track records and are the
best sellers in their field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go including florida the process is
simple just go to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some basic info our team will contact
you to make an intro to our preferred
agent in your town that's it and then
you come back to me and i continue on
with the show all right so
these people
these people who are still lying to us
who are in joe biden's case trying to
freak us out about monkey pox in the
kovidzar's case people who are trying to
tell us that things that we never said
are things that we said
and then in the case of sunny hostin
these people who are just hysterical
controlling maniacs we should not be
paying attention to them anymore
and also we have to remember who
got us here
so this is before the 2020 election this
is a couple days before the 2020
election when uh kovid was running
rampant and joe biden was telling us he
was going to stop it and trump was a
murderer and all that stuff and you may
remember gay pete he's now our
transportation secretary and gay pete
had dropped out of the presidential race
because he cut a deal obviously a
backdoor deal to get uh to become part
of the administration so then he went
and became a surrogate on tv for joe
biden
and here he is talking about how
nationwide lockdowns would be pretty
good some countries in europe such as
the uk and france and germany are
actually reinstituting lockdowns if joe
biden wins should another lockdown be on
the table
well hopefully it doesn't come to that
because we will see swift action
coordinating with and supporting public
health authorities telling us what we
can do as citizens without requiring any
kind of mandates but everything has to
be on the table in order to keep
americans safe
everything has to be on the table now
remember kobe got much much worse the
the year of joe biden under cobit was
significantly worse
than donald trump kovitz situation so uh
pete lied there of course and the idea
that they even have the authority to
lock you in your house or anything they
don't have that authority they only have
the authority that we give them people
and i will not be complying anymore i'm
never putting on a mask and i'm never
being locked down again i want to be
very very clear about that and what's
interesting is the more that we fight
back on this stuff the more that we push
on them they slowly start admitting that
they made it all up and that they don't
know what the flying f that they're
doing
you may remember this from a couple
weeks ago fauci basically saying he
doesn't even know if lockdowns work i'm
interested in your reluctance to use the
word lockdown do you think two years on
that they were worth it or were they too
severe
you know i don't think we're ever going
to be able to determine what the right
balance is i think the restrictions if
you want to use that word which i tend
to shy away from
lockdown this certainly prevented a lot
of infections prevented a lot of
hospitalizations
and prevented a lot of deaths there's no
doubt about that
obviously when you do have that kind of
restriction on society there are
unintended negative consequences
particularly in children who are not
allowed to go to school
in the psychological and mental health
aspects it has on children
in the economic stress that it puts on
society in general on individual
families
obviously those are negative
consequences that are unintended
or are they intended because you people
are control freaks who are destroying
trying to destroy the known world so
that you could build back better or
whatever else it is that you're trying
to do right now at the world economic
forum right like i think i think people
are starting to see
what is up here also there's just no
evidence he says the lockdowns obviously
he says obviously they obviously stop
death i mean we just don't know that we
don't know that they obviously stopped
infection well i suppose to some degree
if you completely lock everybody down
it's going to stop some degree of
infection but whatever happens that herd
immunity thing where you'd want young
health healthy people to get covet and
all that stuff so you guys get it you
guys get it i'm only reiterating all
this because i want to show you that
they just don't know what they either
don't know what they're doing or they're
completely inept or they're evil it's
one of those things but we either way we
cannot forget what they did let's jump
back to last november when joe biden was
warning us about the winter of death and
trying to scare the hell out of all of
us and making sure that first responders
who used to be essential they were going
to be fired if they didn't get
vaccinated
first
we must increase vaccinations among the
unvaccinated with new vaccination
requirements
with nearly 80 million eligible
americans who have not gotten vaccinated
many said they were waiting for approval
from the food and drug administration
the fda
well last month the fda granted that
approval
so the time for waiting is over
this summer we made progress through the
combination of vaccine requirements and
incentives as well as the fda approval
four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom or personal
choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
man isn't it something like once you see
what [ __ ] artists these people are
once you really see it once you accept
it and know it like you cannot see the
world any other way that's what their
ultimate red pill is once you know it
then you watch a video like that which
you guys all saw that video that's from
eight months ago right we all saw that
and when he says it's not about personal
freedom and it's not about what is it he
says it's not about freedom and personal
choice yes it damn well is you dementra
ridden old fool
that's exactly what it is but he was
trying to scare the hell out of
everybody and you know what happened he
did scare a lot of people and a lot of
people made a horrible choice that they
did not want to make they then got
vaccinated against their conscience and
then what happened the courts fought
against it and they reversed it
so that even though the food and drug
administration said it was okay and he
talked to the people at the labor board
it turned out that it was
unconstitutional to have companies force
people to be vaccinated and once again
as i said a million times during the
height of this whole thing the idea that
i could say to my employees guys you
have to be injected with some
experimental [ __ ] to work for me is that
cool guys after this we're gonna take
you downstairs and eject you some no
connor's totally not into it michael you
kind of you didn't give me much there oh
no okay okay he wasn't paying attention
uh
it's just all bananas the point is don't
forget and don't forget fouchy just a
couple weeks ago
was pushing for vax mandates on planes
if you're talking about requiring
a vaccination to get on a plane
domestically that is just another one of
the requirements that i think is
reasonable to consider and i think
that's what you're talking about when
you heard me make a comment you know
there's requirements that you might want
to get if you want to get into college
or you want to go to a university or you
want to work in certain places when you
make vaccination a requirement that's
another incentive to get more people
vaccinated if you want to do that with
domestic flights i think that's
something that seriously should be
considered
it's just gross it's just absolutely
gross and let's not forget then a judge
one judge judge mizell know her name
knows who she is she said nope and then
everybody freaking ripped off their
masks and we haven't had mass death
because they have lied about everything
so what's the point of all of this the
point is they are going to try to scare
you they've proven a test
maybe the test of covid wasn't really
about health the test of covet is could
we just put a virus a different virus in
the system right a virus of fear what
can we always do can we always just sort
of
regulate a certain amount of fear in the
system and what can we make people do
and there will be people who will want
lockdowns there are now quarantines the
first world the first country with the
quarantine because of monkey pox i
believe is belgium
if you let them run with this if you let
them make you scared if they see that
you are scared if you see that you're
going help me help me monkey pucks are
coming monkey pucks are here they will
take whatever liberties they can grab
from you and eventually they will stop
giving those liberties back which is why
it's not their liberty
to take or give in the first place you
have god-given rights that make you free
as a human being and the idea that they
can parse these things out when they
want is crazy but unfortunately a lot of
people have made the government god and
the government ate god okay
um
know that there is an election coming
and a lot of weird things are going to
happen whether they're lockdowns mail-in
ballots mandates vaxes masks ramping up
the ukraine war et cetera et cetera it's
all coming so what do you do because i
like solutions around here you know what
you do you just stop complying
here's my governor
did you not get the cdc's memo i don't
see you guys complying
and i say that jokingly but i i think
that that may be a sign
of potentially seeking to do more things
into the future and i think it's very
important that we say
unequivocally
no to lockdowns no to school closures
no two restrictions and no
mandates
floridians are free to choose and all
americans should be free to choose how
they govern their affairs how they take
care of themselves and our families and
they should not be consigned to live
regardless of which state in the union
consigned to live in a faucian dystopia
in which we're governed by the whims of
bureaucratic authorities who care little
for our freedom
little for our aspirations and little
for our happiness no more we can't let
it happen going forward
that's right that's my governor
ron desantis right there and which
sounds right which one do you know is
right in your gut the guy who is saying
we will let you live as you see fit make
choices for yourself decide how you want
to live no more draconian dystopian
control by people who don't care about
you or the people who are just locking
you in your house and injecting you with
things for your own good which one feels
right to you but you know what it's not
just politicians who are going to save
us it ain't politicians believe it or
not it's you and i can't believe this
but we even found a video from cali free
california
here's the money it's going in the jar
cause i mentioned in california this is
oakdale california this is a couple
months back this is students just
regular old students
protesting newsom's mask mandates
tonight hundreds of students in oakdale
banned from class for not wearing their
masks
students say they were following
governor newsome's example after
pictures showed him maskless at the nfc
championship game over the weekend so
will their protests continue and how is
the district responding we're getting
answers
students bare-faced and packed into the
oakdale high school gym
freshman nolan harris was one of them
where by the end of the day there was
about 100 kids in there throughout
oakdale unified's seven campuses more
than a hundred other students ditched
their masks too in protest of governor
newsom's mask mandate if they don't
follow by their own rules that they're
trying to force upon me why should i
follow them oakdale parent melissa
goodman shared these pictures of dozens
of moms and dads outside their child's
school to show their support
don't forget the bravery of that kid
right high school kid nah not going to
do it newsom you're a dick i'm not going
to do it i'm not going to do it so now
let's throw back to the cold open that
we started with uh because this is just
a day or two ago and this once again is
ron desantis because it's not just that
you fight against these people maybe
we're going to do a bit more than that
at the end of the day
[Applause]
how about they feel a little bit of fear
right they love fear winter or death
you're all gonna die
numbers are going crazy they love
making us
be fearful how about they feel a little
bit of fear i hope you feel a little bit
of fear today anthony foucher you should
feel a little bit of fear so we were
discussing before the show all right so
how do we wrap this thing up what really
is
the message
because there are so many lives right
and we all know this that i think that's
why most of you guys watch this i can
try to pilfer a little bit of truth out
of the out of the lunacy that's what
you're trying to do in your own life and
then
and then hopefully you can go ahead and
live a life that you think is worthy of
living uh and then yesterday i was
flipping through the instagram
and i saw this great video of uh
my buddy my mentor my friend jordan
peterson talking about why truth is
important partly what i'm doing is
helping people walk through
thinking about why telling the truth is
a good idea not as a top down shake your
finger moral injunction don't lie you
shouldn't lie but in a detailed manner
to explain the relationship between the
instrumental use of deceit and the
collapse of civilizations and that
connection is way closer than people
think well it turns out that what you do
matters and
basically what i'm doing is touring and
talking to people face to face everyone
says well we want meaning in our life
do you now because you might ask
yourself what's the more threatening
possibility that nothing you do matters
which means you can pretty much do
whatever you want that's the upside of
that nihilistic claim no responsibility
right and why why not pursue narrow
focused hedonism since nothing matters
anyways so that's the shadow of nihilism
or everything you do matters
i love the guy i love the guy
that deceit and the collapse of
civilization these things are connected
really think about that what if it's
through a million cuts right it's a
thousand cuts
that destroy a civilization that kill a
human being and that all of us to the
extent that we don't put truth into the
world that every time something bad
happens something dishonest happens we
don't fight it or we add to the lies
it's not just that we don't fight it
that's that's one version but the worst
version is that we somehow add to the
lie we know something bad is happening
we know something that we that we all
just know is not true is happening and
we don't do anything to stop it or
we actually enhance it by lying along
with it because it's easier to do it
because it seems like that's the easy
way out that over time that will
actually lead to the collapse of
civilization does that kind of feel like
what might be happening right now it
kind of does doesn't it and then what is
the answer to that what is the answer to
that well perhaps the answer to that is
knowing that you actually have a little
bit of a role in fixing the thing that
if you in your life do a little bit more
a little bit more whatever that means no
i will not comply no i will not put that
mask on no i will not yell at my
neighbor no i will not snitch
whatever that is it's not just all about
covid it's about the whole damn thing
but if you acted a little more honestly
in your
business affairs and your personal
affairs all of those things and you
stood up straight with your shoulders
back and you said to the world here i am
this is what i believe
um do you think you might be able to fix
this thing
and look i know some of this is is a bit
this is an ongoing theme in what i do
here obviously um but they are coming
back with the lies the monkey pox thing
is just another version of the game that
they're constantly running on us don't
fall for it again guys do not fall for
it again we have a great uh cold close
that's gonna sort of wrap this thing
together in terms of lies and the
buffoonery of the people in charge but
real quick let's get to some comments
from reubenreport.locals.com
pat says u.s health department is
running horrendous tv ads urging
grandparents to make sure their
grandchildren are vaccinated and falsely
implying that kovid is a major danger to
little kids i have not seen that i don't
have cable tv
but again the entire machine is set
up to make you scared and make
grandchild turn against grandparent and
grandparent turn against parent and
parent turn against child and all of
that stuff and we've all got the dramas
in our families
and man
don't let it win don't let it win olaf
says one of my co-workers is leaving
washington state for florida this fall
well as long as they vote the right way
as long as they vote the right way then
we will be happy to have them here
and donda says can't wait to see you and
governor desantis in orlando well i
can't wait to see you either and as i
mentioned yesterday for all paying
members of the locals community i am
hosting a breakfast it's fully on me all
you want on the morning of june 3rd
afterwards you can find out more info on
that at rubinport.locals.com
i think you got the theme today guys
let's fix the freaking thing i'm really
feeling that right now after being out
on the road like seeing you guys again
and being around it again and feeling
the energy and the laughter and and
hugging the people and shaking the hands
and all of that stuff
it's on us it's on us they're they are
never gonna save us there will be a
couple markers and a couple good people
along the way that can help whether it's
ron desantis or it's jordan peterson or
whoever whoever it is in your life
whether it's a teacher or your husband
or wife or a mentor or something
it's on you person watching this
that that's that's it that's all i got
all right i've enjoyed today's show and
now
joe biden
what people drastically underestimate is
the impact on the mental health
of people who now everything is
complicated not only is the health care
piece but
people don't have a job people don't
have anywhere to go they don't know what
they're going to do and a lot of people
you have
unnecessarily now we have over 120
million dead from covent